hey everybody it's Zachary Levi Lucy Liu
Asher Angel and Jacqueline Angel and
we're here with BuzzFeed playing who's
who that was my line oh was it yes I
don't know dude I'm having an ego death
[Music]
that's tough
both well you have no power
she's far too cool nice yeah anywhere
near her character she's committed
yeah
I think yeah
[Music]
or maybe Zachariah probably Zach I would
say Zach I think I actually I think I
would take that it's not his first time
not my first rodeo or plan bait for that
matter don't give away the plot
he's probably that guy oh my God he
likes to improvise and fall yes
all of the above
[Music]
definitely this guy okay really good at
some Secrets but just wins that don't
tell them anything you want to keep
run them now what other Secrets big
mouth do I have a secret to share with
BuzzFeed Are you kidding everybody's
trying to get myself last out here no I
do not good solid answer solid answer
he's cork in it
not this guy me she likes her oysters
and suckers I like Clambake yeah they
have a really good cranberry crafty
[Music]
um
I'll take it but really gosh he's a
professional musician singer wow okay
we've got choreography you haven't done
anything like that let's see that all
right nothing but a hound no if you do
it like that I do know yeah
yeah good okay
this is Asher
I don't see I don't know anyone what are
you talking about we're all pretty Live
Wire yeah
Devon sometimes takes naps
easy sack every day
when we did three shoes
Lucy
Lucy's this guy did not nail us down
remember the time that I jumped off that
thing and I made Helen mirror laugh when
I jumped off the when you nearly knocked
into hell yeah 17 takes later
yeah
I'll take the stunts I'll I'll hold the
stunts
Lucy maybe yeah I didn't tell anyone
about my kid until he was born your Q
would be like you have a kid what
[Music]
Rachel zegler Rachel and DJ were the two
on point in the in the thread they were
always sending the funniest memes and
even creating them they're meme creators
they're main creators on their resume
they didn't even mention you no no I'm
not in the group chat they didn't let me
in they blocked you because you can't
keep a secret exactly my memes are too
disturbing for their small little brains
shallow minded freaks
Zach definitely not Zach
of course
[Laughter]
yeah and make sure to watch Shazam two
Fury of the Gods on a movie theater
screen or in your own home whichever one
you prefer more thank you have a
beautiful day tomorrow will be even
better ellipses it's like the longest
round trip
thank you
[Music]